bevor wir in einer minute mit wladimir
klitschko in kiew sprechen werden
schauen wir noch kurz auf ein
gruppenbild aus der rubrik finde den
fehler heute nachmittag der polnische
präsident ist da der litauische der
lettische der estnische nur einer fehlt
der deutsche frank walter steinmeier hat
er an diesem solidaritätsbesuch
ebenfalls teilnehmen wollen aber
ukrainische präsident sie lenski hat ihn
bekanntlich ausgeladen hat den deutschen
bundespräsidenten zu unerwünschten
person in der ukraine erklärt eine
beispiellose brüskierung die in
deutschland in weiten teilen und auch
parteiübergreifend auf unverständnis
stößt aber auch in der ukraine gibt es
kritik an der entscheidung von präsident
see lenski und zwar von wladimir
klitschko der uns jetzt live aus der
ukrainischen hauptstadt zugeschaltet des
guten abend herr klitschko nahm
klitschko warum halten sie die
ausladungen des deutschen
bundespräsidenten für falsch
natürlich ich hab schon davon gesagt
natürlich
präsident deutsche bundespräsident
war mit der großen politik eher
freundlicher vorher hat die fehler aber
anerkannt und er war einer der ersten
der auch diesen krieg also herrscht
einmal der bundespräsident steinmeier
hat kritisiert auch diesen putins krieg
und er war eine der westliche liedes der
sich eine der ersten die sich dafür
geäußert hat
diese anerkannte fehler
und das was in der vergangenheit war
heute werden des krieges muss man auch
sagen man muss die farbe bekennen und
ich glaube dass mit den aussagen hat
bundespräsident die die frauen erkannt
wofür steht war für sein land steht und
ich möchte hier keinen kritisieren und
nicht die entscheidung revision besitzen
keine politischen amt
ich bin ein aktivist und ich äußere nur
das was ich denke ich hätte
deutschen bundespräsidenten heute gern
gesehen weil ich glaube das was
deutschland ukraine seit 2004 10
geleistet hat hat kein anderes land
gemacht und deutschland für die ukraine
ist ein ganz wichtiger partner und diese
bürger darf auf keinen fall verbrannt
werden ich stehe für die einigung und
ich habe auch gesehen nach meinen zwei
tagen besuch in deutschland dass das
deutsche volk und die durch regierung
stieg werde eins mit einer front
gegenüber diese sinnlose screens die
russland angefangen hat und deswegen in
diese einigung brauchen wir jetzt auch
diese stärke ist stärke wo man gemeinsam
und nicht alleine steht gegen diesen
blutigen schrecklichen kriegte gerade in
lublin herrschte bei aller solidarität
die sie ansprechen in deutschland herr
klitschko gibt es aber auch an menschen
die denken dass die ukrainische
regierung undankbar sein dass ihr
präsident und auch seinen botschafter
trotz aller hilfe immer mehr fordern und
die deutsche regierung kritisieren was
sagen sie diesen menschen
ich glaube dass die kritik in gewissen
maßen auch zu recht ist in gewissen
maßen nur ich betone es noch einmal man
muss die farbe bekennen am gewissen
zeitpunkt um seit 49 darin
herrscht diese sinnlose krieg und man
steht entweder auf einer seite des
krieges oder auf die andere seite und
deutschland hat sich dafür bekannt
gemacht dass deutschland steht
gegen diesen krieg und das bestätige ich
nach meinem besuch und mit allen
schlüssen politiker
repräsentanten der deutschen regierung
zu 100 prozent steht gegen
russland mit einer front auf seite der
ukraine und die fehle die vorher war man
erkennen dass oder hat schon erkannt und
unterstützt die creme ich nein weil ich
wiederhole ich besitze kein politisches
amt und ich äußere mich als jenige der
hat lange in deutschland gelebt kennt
auch persönlich
die leute die in deutschland sind auf
der politischen ebene auf normale
drucker ebene und auch in der ukraine
das gleiche und ich glaube dass ich
verstehe diese bald beide welten sehr
sehr gut und ich möchte auf keinen fall
hier
kritik ausgeben während des krieges auch
mit kritik muss man vorsichtig umgehen
einigung und ich möchte auch für
stattfinden für beide seiten absolut
aber ich würd auch klar sagen unklar
stehen deutschland ist
freundlich
unterstützend und wichtig für die
europäische union für die ukraine für
das frieden der ukraine wie die
unterstützung der ukraine die wie gesagt
so schon viel und stark geleistet worden
wie kein anderes land seit 2004 sind und
vor allem während dieses krieges
deutschland hat eine enorme
unterstützung gegeben wie die ukraine
und dass das darf man nicht wegstreichen
auf keinen fall sollen ich möchte loben
und natürlich mit diesem logo und mit
mit unseren mit unseren bedürfnissen auf
fragen bitte unterstützen sie es weiter
wir brauchen dies unterstützen wir
brauchen diese hilfe wir brauchen
frieden in europa um frieden steht dubai
alle über jede kritik wir müssen
gemeinsam diesen frieden
wiederherstellen nur gemeinsam können
wir es schneller schaffen als allein
allein werden wir fallen gemeinsam
werden wir stark sein diese
unterstützung werden sie natürlich auch
weiter aus deutschland bekommen und auch
aus der bevölkerung
nun steht die einladung an bundeskanzler
olaf scholz ja weiterhin der hat
allerdings heute gesagt dass er vorerst
keine pläne habe nach kiew zukommen
würden sie sich wünschen herr klitschko
dass olaf scholz der deutsche
bundeskanzler nach kiew kommt
natürlich wünsche mir dass
bundeskanzler scholz nachkommt ich
wünsche mir auch dass steinmeier wenn
nicht jetzt dann vielleicht später nach
ihm kommen wird und ich wünsche mir dass
wir weiter diese unterstützung von
deutschland bekommen es ist enorm
wichtig und ich glaube
irgendwelche ambitionen oder
gefühle in dem sinne wie auch immer man
muss auch die seite schieben für ein
ziel wie sind auf eine seite des flusses
sozusagen
gegenüber von russland und die sekretion
verlust an diesem krieg der wahnsinnig
viel leid verursacht hat deutschland und
die ukraine wie sind zu sagen wie sind
zusammen und wir schaffen es zu sagen
und ich möchte auch die politiker dafür
bieten dass nur einmal es so eine
klarheit kommt und zu einer einigung
kommt und ich wünsche noch einmal dass
herr steinmeier
nachkommt zeit seine solidarität
was er schon auch angeboten hat genauso
wie herr bundeskanzler
klitschko ostern steht vor der tür
glauben sie an gott beten sie
ich ja bitte
dass dieser krieg
ein ende findet und
zwar schnell
es ist wichtig
die bilder die wir
am ort ihr dann natürlich durch medien
mitbekommen habt was in der ukraine
passiert
ist einfach schrecklich und die bilder
manchmal
erzählen nicht alles und zeigen nicht
alles
dass das leiden und das leiden wollen
wenn man unter den menschen ist
besser kriegt als nur die bilder die
bilder bleiben aber läge im kopf hängen
als das was auch gerade gesagt wird und
ich möchte keine weitere bilder dieses
schreckliche bilder sehen ich möchte das
ist ein ende hat und natürlich bitter
für
ketsch vor ganz herzlichen dank für
dieses gespräch und alles gute nach er
danke bleiben sie mit doppel zusammen
und bitte unterstützen sie weiter vielen
dank danke ihnen